former advisor to the US president Roger
stone has been found guilty of seven
offenses including lying to Congress and
witness tampering stone was charged
earlier this year during the House of
Representatives intelligence committees
investigation into Russian interference
in the 2016 election let's cross now to
Paddy cocaine in a Washington force so
patty what more we're hearing on this
well the jury has just come back they
didn't deliberate for very long just
about seven hours over two days so now
we know Roger stone the self labeled
dirty trickster of politics is facing
some time in prison as you mentioned
guilty and all seven counts that he was
charged on that included obstructing an
official investigation obstructing
justice lying to Congress which is a
crime so the bottom line here is the
connection between WikiLeaks and those
hacked Democratic emails now Roger stone
publicly would go on Twitter before they
were released and say something's coming
but then when he was asked about it in
Congress as part of their ongoing
investigation into Russian interference
into the u.s. election he basically said
was at me it was coincidence I was
looking at public statements didn't have
any emails didn't have any phone calls
didn't talk to the campaign was it me so
then the because of the robert muller
investigation the special counsel he was
brought up on charges these seven
charges because they actually produced
text messages emails phone calls
witnesses who said yes that was in fact
Roger stone he was trying to be the
go-between between WikiLeaks and the
campaign and one testified that he even
directly told the president it was then
a candidate that WikiLeaks was about to
do these dumps so what now well he's
facing some pretty serious time in
prison potentially up to 50 years in
prison but that said they'll go through
federal guidelines and there's all sorts
of line items that they go through he's
not been convicted before he is no it
wasn't a violent crime so he's probably
facing a lot less time than that
this is Roger stone and this is a man
who basically thought that he could he
likes to think of himself as being able
to talk his way out of things but he
didn't really put on much of a defense a
lot of legal analysts were wondering
what exactly
the strategy was he didn't try to defend
himself on the stand
his lawyers basically played some of his
testimony and that was basically it
so his strategy of saying little didn't
work now he can hopefully he's probably
hoping that the president his old friend
will give him a pardon yeah and this as
we were saying this is this is a case
that grew out of the Special Counsel
Robert Mueller's investigation into
alleged Russian meddling in the 2016
election so how how significantly does
this affect president Trump where does
he fit into this in terms of legal hot
water well it very much significantly
impacts him not necessarily that he's
going to be brought up in charges for
any of the having ties to this because
again as we know the Justice Department
has a long-standing rule that a sitting
president cannot be prosecuted for a
crime but the question is if he doesn't
pardon him does that send a broader
signal to all of the people who are now
and the focus of Congress the Rudy
Giuliani's of the world who may actually
decide you know what it's probably time
for me to testify so far they've
basically been stonewalling Congress
saying yeah no I'm not going to talk to
you if he doesn't step in and help stone
avoid what could be some serious prison
time that would send the message to all
of these people in his orbit that he
won't be there for them if they get into
trouble and it is widely believed that
Rudy Giuliani is facing some serious
legal challenges two of his associates
have been already indicted by a federal
prosecutor for campaign finance
violations there's questions about how
much was being paid by Ukraine if he was
being paid by Ukraine so he could be in
a lot of hot legal water he has the
president's loyalty to count on for this
because remember when it comes to
federal crimes which is what Roger stone
is facing the president has carte
blanche ability to do what he wants with
pardons he can pardon any can commute a
sentence
so those around the president are going
to be watching closely to see how the
president responds to stone stone for
his part obviously a very flamboyant
character known for his interesting suit
choices and the fact that he has a
tattoo of Richard Nixon's full face on
his entire back he likes to talk this is
going to be hard for him when he leaves
court you're gonna be thinking he's
gonna really
Lode nope he can't the judges are issued
a gag order on him until he's sentenced
in February so he might try to defy it
but well wait and see what he does he
doesn't like to stay quiet all right
patty : lifers there in Washington
thanks patty